- You definitely don't need to be
a lumberjack to be an ax-thrower.
Anybody can do it, all shapes and sizes,
men, women, all different kinds.
(upbeat music)
My name's Matt Wilson, we are at BATL,
the Backyard Axe Throwing League,
we're at the Toronto west location.
- [Group] Remember proud
men, who only have—
- [Matt] BATL is a community based around
the activity of ax-throwing.
(horn)
What is ax-throwing?
It's exactly that, it's throwing an ax
at a target for points.
Standard match format is
three rounds of five throws
per round, and you have to win
two out three rounds to win that match.
It started with me learning how to
throw an ax at a cottage.
There's a whole lot of force up here,
that's sort of how the
initial idea started
and it was super addictive.
This is like the culmination of many years
of debauchery and boredom.
Just straight up, like, I threw an ax
and it was fun and we went from there.
This is one of eight locations in Ontario
and we have one in Alberta as well.
We definitely didn't invent the activity,
we just invented a different
way to do it that I think
works a little better in
heavily-populated areas.
Would I have started if
I didn't live in Canada,
I don't know, I think
Toronto, it's a pretty
world-class city that's
open to trying new things
and taking on some new adventures
and so people were very open-minded to it.
I find a lot of people
in the city of Toronto
that share values and ideals with myself
and within BATL we try
to operate with a sense
of fairness and acceptance
and equality across the board.
We're already talking to
people overseas, people in
Australia and Poland and
England, let alone the States.
I think the sport can be huge.